bonjour bonjour et merci stéphanie nous
accueillir dans votre galerie c'est
gentil et moi la mont-bruno bruno c'est
vous qui allez nous raconter l'histoire
du quartier on va peut-être se faire un
petit tour dans la galerie on en profite
c'est comme ça on sera content ah c'est
super joli mais alors expliquez-moi
bruno pourquoi ce quartier qui était
très vivant un quartier de maraîchers un
quartier de commerçants finalement va
subir un déclin à partir du xviiie bien
parce qu'au xviiie siècle la route de
postes qui arrivait à blois par la
gauche va passer sur la rive droite et
donc plus de trafic plus d'auberge et
donc ça commence à décliner ajoutez à
cela plusieurs autres facteurs
l'implantation de l'hôpital général avec
une population de malades pauvres gens
puis dans les années 1970 un hôpital
psychiatrique avec une population de
malades mentaux mais en semi liberté
ajoutez à cela quelques établissements
un peu mal famés dont un cinéma qui
passent des films
voilà c'est ça quelques boîtes de nuit
pas trop bien fréquenté voilà plus un
seul pont entre la ville et le faubourg
donc des difficultés de communication
certains jours il faut une demi heure
pour passer le pont d'accord si on n'a
pas de raison d'aller en vient on n'y va
pas en il apparemment c'est ça mais
alors justement vous dites on vienne en
plus j'aime bien est ce que vous
connaissez
l'origine du nom de ce quartier l'ancien
bien sûr ça vient de in soula edena
c'est comme ça qu'on a la première
mention du lieu d'après événement sais
pas d'où ça vient et une soul à moi j'ai
fait de latin à l'école ça veut dire
qu'elle fait ça veut dire fils alors on
a longtemps cru et on l'a même expliqué
on a même montré des cartes
géologiquement parlant c'est fou vienne
n'a jamais été une ils viennent et une
île que lorsque la loire déborde la
loire où le son on l'a vu en 2016
lorsque que son a débordé médecin
effectivement était devenue une il y
avait plus de communication donc toutes
les cartes convoi qui nous montre
ensuite arriver là avec
ses défauts scarpe absolument
les amoureux comment notre quartier
vienne redevient à la mode voir
maintenant pratiquement un pistolet
alors je paye ce toubib parce que
d'abord il ya d'autres ponts donc on va
beaucoup plus facilement 11e et du coup
facilement et ben il y avait là il ya de
nouveaux quartiers qui apparaissent donc
vous quartier de nouvelles populations
en même temps on re découvre
les maisons anciennes le fait qu'ils
aient plus d'ide hôpital général ni de
plan psychiatrique fait perdre au
quartier se ce côté un peu populaire un
peu peuple qui pouvaient gêner certaines
personnes et donc du coup et bien on se
réapproprie vienne il ya des nouveaux
commerces qui arrivent notamment une
excellente charcuterie
tribunaux et puis bah très bientôt un
hôtel cinq étoiles donc qui
effectivement redore un peu le blason du
quartier en tout cas il fait vraiment
changé de physionomie c'est ça parce que
on a un renouveau finalement des
enseignes qui se fait depuis plusieurs
années ici c'est un exemple et ben voilà
l'ancien cinéma bilson qui devient une
galerie d'art ça c'était tout à fait
inattendu et peut-être même inespéré
proviennent galerie d'art je crois
associative et inclusive en plus qu'est
votre petit coin préféré à vous qui
connaissez très bien et quartier qui
reviennent c'est un quartier de sentiers
ça reste encore un quartier rural et se
perdre dans tous les petits sentiers et
il ya plein de surprises en vue tout à
fait donc il ya plein de choses à faire
plein de balades de sentiers mais je
crois que c'est aussi un quartier
historiquement le sport de loisir ça
c'est au xvième siècle on a plusieurs
jeu de paume donc on vient jouer à la
paume c'est à dire au tennis en viennent
il ya eu longtemps un stade vélodrome
maintenant il ya la piscine agglo il ya
les courts de tennis et puis juste avant
la guerre de 14 années j'ai repensé il
ya eu une piste de patins à roulettes
inscrits thing est ce à dire que déjà
comme ça à ce casting un skating rink
pour patins à roulettes fonctionne tous
les jours de 9 heures du matin à minuit
les leçons sont gratuites sa salle
étonnant quand même
une super anecdotes miliboo ce livre je
vous le donne mais la marque et bris de
guignard ça c'est votre bébé
là on apprend plein de choses sur blu à
vienne bon on a fui votre votre conseil
du coup chez renault on a prévu de se
balader toute la journée sur le quartier
merci d avoir appris autant de choses
merci de m'avoir invité et à bientôt